In the last lesson,
we began to define what computation is
with a goal of eventually being precise
about what it can and cannot do.
We said that the input to any
computation can be expressed as a string
and may assume that whatever
the instructions that were for
turning input into output, that these
two could be expressed as a string.
Using a counting argument,
we were able to show that there were
some functions that were not computable.
In this lesson we're going to look
at how input gets turned into
output more closely.
Specifically, we're going to
study the Turing machine and
the classical model of computation.
As we'll see in a later lesson, Turing
machines can do everything that we
consider as computation and
because of their simplicity
they are a terrific tool for studying
computation and its limitations.
Massively parallel machines,
quantum computers,
they can't doing anything a that
a Turing machine can't do.
Turing machines were never
intended to be practical but
nevertheless several have been built for
illustrative purposes.
Including this one, from Mike Davey.
The input to the machine is a tape, unto
which the string input has been written.
Using a read right head,
the machine turns input into output,
through a series of steps.
At each step,
a decision is made about whether and
what to write to the tape, and whether
to move it to the right or to the left.
This decision is based
on exactly two things.
The current symbol under
the read write head and
something called the machine state.
Which also gets updated
as the symbol is written.
That's it.
The machine stops when is reaches one of
two halting states,
named accept and reject.
Usually we're interested in which of
these two states the machine halts in.
Though when we want to compute
functions from strings to strings,
then we pay attention to
the tape contents instead.
It's a very interesting historical
note that in Alan Turing's 1936 paper,
in which he first proposed this model,
the inspiration does not seem to come
from any thought of
an electromechanical device, but
rather from the experience of
doing computations on paper.
In section 9 he starts from the idea
of a person who he calls the computer,
working with pen and paper, and
then argues that his proposed machine
can do what this person does.
So here I am, a computer,
with my pen and paper.
And we'll follow Turing's argument
that his machine can do what I can.
Let's take an example.
He's talking about computable numbers,
so I'll compute a very simple number,
Alan Turing's age when
he wrote the paper.
So we'll take 1936- 1912,
which is equal to 24.
He argues that any calculation
like this can be done on a grid.
Like a child's arithmetic book her says.
I assume he means something
like wide ruled graph paper.
He argues that all the symbols can be
made to fit inside one of these squares.
Then he argues that the fact
that the grid is two dimensional
is just a convenience.
So he takes away the paper and says
that computation can be done on a tape.
As someone who has to carry out the
computation, I don't much care for this.
But I can still do my job.
Then he points out that there are limits
to the width of my perception.
So if I happen to be reading
a very long mathematical paper,
the phrase "hence (applying this
big Theorem number) we have.
Then when I look back,
I probably wouldn't be sure at a glance
that I had found the right theorem.
I would have to check, maybe three or
four digits at a time,
crossing off the ones I had matched,
so as not to lose my place.
Something like this.
So I match the first four,
then the next four, and so on.
And so forth.
Eventually, I will have matched them
all and can re-read the theorem.
Now, since Alan Turing was going for
the simplest machine possible,
he takes this idea to extreme and only
let's me read one symbol at a time and
only move right or left one square
on the tape at a time trusting
to the strategy of making marks on the
tape like I did with this theorem here,
and my state mind to accomplish
the same things as I would
under normal operation with pen and
paper.
And with those rules,
I have become a Turing machine.
So that's the inspiration, not
a futuristic vision of the digital age,
but probably Alan Turing's own
everyday experience of computing
with pen and paper.